[Music]
we've known each other a while and we're
very good friends some say best friends
and you deny it but but I'm curious bill
named Gyllenhaal I never know if I'm
pronouncing it correctly it is a Swedish
name is it not it is a swedishness Oh
shouldn't be like healing are the only
two places that that is pronounce
correctly my last name like you did just
now is in Sweden huh and in IKEA Swedes
you know we're pretty great people I
mean I'm half Swedish you know but we're
pretty great people and you know we come
with simple instructions and we seem
really great and then at the end of it
your fingers are sore does this make you
feel like at home with your people I'm
with my people you know now I can't stop
doing it Thank You Thomas don't we can
own this if I keep doing it it's gonna
start when you're walking on the street
I could ruin your life right I have to I
have to help you with it is actually
yielding Hey look you and hello there
what is your name Andy and it's print
out in its correct tongue reach to reach
them yeah yeah it's the weird hits the
weird gyro comedy team of Utah